okay good afternoon my name is Chris
Blackman I'm an assistant professor in
political science department on behalf
of the Office of Public Affairs which
administers the Pointer fellowship in
journalism at Yale I'd like to welcome
and renew and I'd like to welcome all of
you to and thank you for coming to hear
Andrew speak there used to be a time
when you couldn't work in East Africa
without hearing what Andrew Munda has to
say on every topic imaginable he is on
radio he is in the newspapers he is on
the lips of conversations in the street
everywhere he goes he stirs up
controversy he speaks truth to power he
streaks truth to the somewhat powerful
he speaks truth to the less powerful to
the powerless he'll speak truth if if
you're willing to listen and I'm glad
that you all are here today I said he
used to just hear me say Africa this is
because you now hear him all over the
world
he he's increasingly one of the most
vocal and influential and thoughtful
voices outside the foreign aid
establishment on foreign aid this year
foreign policy magazine named him one of
the hundred most influential global
policy thinkers in the world and he was
one of the very few Africans to make the
list and certainly one of the very very
few Africans not a former head of state
his former book which you're going to
get a taste of today you will hear but
again hopefully we see it out next year
and for some sense that's exactly the
reason we invited him here to come to
Yale for the semester is to lock him in
an office make him stop talking and get
him to write it all down so the Pointer
fig of fellowship brings distinguished
journalists to campus and has given Yale
students a unique opportunity Laura but
the world of journalism and its role in
society and I think Andrews going to
give us a very unique perspective on
journalism in in its role in society
journalists as public intellectuals in
as political activists and and and and
indeed he's among the most distinguished
journalists in
Africa he's the founding managing editor
of the independent which is you ganas
premier innovator current affairs news
magazine he is he's also he runs Andrew
Melinda today is it is that the correct
title of your radio show something like
Andrew Melinda live that's right with
roughly I think two million two million
listeners in in a country of thirty
million is not too bad and so this is
he's one of the main and major sir
mainstream news personalities in Africa
he's the former political editor of the
deal your monitor newspaper and in
Ugandan is in Africa he's been an
outspoken voice for Liberty
this has landed him in jail had seen his
articles and his newspapers suppressed
it seen his publishing interfered with
at every turn by the states he by the
state he has won many awards including
the International Press Freedom Award
from the International Committee to
Protect Journalists there's going to be
a brief Q&A section following the talk
if you'd like to ask a question these
microphones will be on either side and I
think we'll be able to pass them through
the audience I'm also happy to say
andrew is around until the end of April
so we have them for the entire semester
and he and I'm sure he'd love to hear
from you if you if you want to continue
and continue the conversation that we
start today and just so a quick note
this event is being video recorded so a
quick reminder to turn off your cell
phones pagers and other miscellaneous
electronic devices and without further
ado please join me in welcoming Andrew
Melinda
thank you very much Chris for that
generous introduction
Chris didn't tell you that among my the
other things on my CV is that they face
23 criminal charges in Uganda with
accumulative jail sentence of 115 years
so if I was jailed I will come out in
2125 AD in time tradeable president
running for his 28th term of office
right now he has been six the topic from
a presentation today is paved with good
intentions
Africa and the caste of foreign aid now
I am a journalist not an academic and I
am trained to tell stories so I'll begin
by telling the story and at the risk of
sounding extremely modest the story will
be about me and my father
in 1993 I passed my high school exams
very well and my father bought me a gift
it wasn't a huge box but when they
removed the gift it was a small book by
a man called Frederick von von hayek and
the book was titled the road Suffern
Suffern dom is something akin to slavery
and this is what the book had to tell me
Hayek sought to demonstrate the title
nexus between politics and economics and
argued that centralized planning of
economic life would inevitably under
main political freedom and lead the West
over the Western world towards
totalitarian government hack was
concerned to the threat posed the threat
to individual liberty caused by economic
insecurity in the Western world after
the Great Depression and how it had
given socialism ideologically ascendance
in policymaking suckers
many people at that time argued that
they made the government's to intervene
in markets in order to correct market
failures and Hayek from this argument
extremely you tell you he found this
argument utopian and argued that it
ignored the vital role of markets in
determining or finding people's new ones
and he always argued in towards the end
of the book that we should always as
much as possible try to rely on the
spontaneous forces of society rather
than on commanded decisions by
governments and his most important
insight was that suffered on which was
totalitarian government would not be
brought to Western Europe or North
America by the evil actions of evil men
like Joseph Stalin and Adolf Hitler but
by the cumulative effect of actions of
well-intentioned people whose actions
will always be generated by immediate
necessity but whose long-term impact was
to undermine the basis of freedom now
Hayek may have overstated his guest in
the front of the market and against the
state but I wanted to use the story of
what I learned from higher to come to my
subject of discussion and that is the
international movement towards
increasing financial systems to poorer
countries because this movement is based
on the idea that the advancement of
society is not a product of the
spontaneous actions of individuals in
the marketplace that the advancement of
society is based on a huge humanitarian
intervention by the international
community through massive transfers of
financial resources from rich countries
to poorer countries and these resources
are channeled through the state I am
deeply suspicious of this new argument
in favor of something they call a
Marshall Plan for Africa now I should
introduce the Marshall Plan the Marshall
Plan was a massive injection of
financial resources into Western Europe
after the Second World War by the night
many observers say that this master plan
succeeded now I I am extremely skeptic
about the achievements of the Marshall
Plan but since I do not want sound like
I'm the skeptic who refuses the
International and global consensus let
me accept that the master plan helped
the constructor of the second world war
but the context of the master plan was
different in the following ways one the
master plan fans were not given for the
development of Europe of Western Europe
they were given for the reconstruction
of Western Europe after the devastation
of the Second World War true Europe had
undergone had already undergone by that
time 1945 1946 1950 Europe had undergone
two major transitions the transition
from an agrarian or agriculture based
economy to an industrial based economy
and with it and associated out
transition the transition of most people
from living in rural areas to urban
areas 3 Europe by that time had
developed skills in terms of the spread
of Education and knowledge but also the
Europe had acquired technology Europe
had also acquired the social
infrastructure of a capitalist society
in other words capitalist enormous
habits practices had penetrated the
social consciousness of the Western
person or the European the Western
European person finally the Second World
War had destroyed the physical
infrastructure in Europe but the
structure infrastructure of skills
technology capture slums habits and
others who are still in within the
society even capitalist institutions now
today let us look at Africa most
Africans are not urban and most of them
depend on agricultural industry for a
living there is limited human skill
because the spirit of Education is
limited and the diffusion of modern
technology is very stunting agrarian
nomes
habits and practices still dominated the
social
justice over all societies what then has
been the result processor because of the
context that they presented in Europe
the Marshall Plan funds which were only
2.5 percent of the GDP of the alleged
recipients France the United Kingdom and
Germany where about spa rapidly
transformation on the other hand since
1960 Africa has received on average for
an aid to the tune of 13% of its GDP
every historian even a poor historian
will tell you that this is an app an
unprecedented transfer of financial
resources from rich countries to poorer
countries now this is the paradox after
50 years of massive transfers of money
into these poor countries the continent
of Africa has burned poor not Richard
say the continent most countries in
Africa have burned poorer not richer in
spite of this practical evidence there
is still there are still loud voices
that are saying that we should increase
aid I am suspicious that that approach
is like saying that the patient is
getting worse buy this medicine and the
solution is we should give them more of
it now before I go into why I think Aid
has been destructive to Africa in spite
of the good intentions that underpin it
I want to present the following two
caveats one when I say Africa I am
actual excluding South Africa Botswana
Namibia to south and Egypt Libya Morocco
Tunisia and Algeria to the north largely
because the Arab countries to the north
I don't understand the politics very
well and these other countries in the
South Botswana Namibia and South Africa
have their politics is organized
differently
the second coverage the countries I'll
be referring to a large and diverse
group of countries with the different
cultures and traditions and a sometimes
different politics and there are four
I'll be making sometimes
sweeping generalizations but I will ask
you for the following favor
that the generations I make for every
generalization I will make here I am
100% certain that there will be some
exceptions divergences and what I would
call counter narratives now with those
caveats in it in place I am I will try
to get one thread around the
organization of an agrarian society that
can cut through all of these countries
there is the second challenge to the
argument that I am going to make how do
we explain the outcome of foreign aid in
countries like South Korea and Taiwan
and Botswana which used aid where aid
let me put it this way where these
countries were able to transform rapidly
in spite of or possibly because of the
presence of page and then how do we
balance that against against Somalia
Liberia Zaire a my own country Uganda
Kenya Tanzania all these other countries
which have grown poorer in spite of and
they want also to add also because of
huge influx of foreign aid concluded my
caveat I want to say that my argument is
that aid in and of itself is not a bad
thing aid is just one input among so
many other variables that operate in a
poorer country the impact of a donor
country is determined by the
organization of the intern organization
of its politics how is power organized
how is power exercised and how is power
reproduced in that country it is in
understanding those three that we can be
able to understand the negative
consequences of paid in African
economies let me map a picture of how
power is organized in Africa and I will
begin by telling a story like any
generals who do in 2003 I visited the
former president of Zambia Zambia is a
small little country in East Africa in
central fraca and the president at the
time was called Frederick Chiluba
and we sat over a meal of Oh
rice chapati and wild game delicious and
he started telling me at that time he
had left power and he had installed
somebody to replace him that person is
called the levy who was called living
man I was unfortunate and he died in
office about three years ago she never
told me that
when awasa had gone to Parliament and
removed immunity on him so that he can
be tried for corruption we were not
still in office and he felt a big sense
of betrayal that the this guy whom he
had made the president could do
something like Raj to him why in the mid
nineties a man called when I was a who
later became president had good and
involved in a bad accident and Chiluba
had been informed that he's about to die
and out of his own kindness mr. chillip
approached manasa on a plane evacuated
him to South Africa and let a Briton who
he received first world treatment and it
is on the basis of that high-class
medical care that this guy's life was
saved and children felt that from when I
was that not reciprocate that act of
generosity and kindness saving his life
was very an African why did you ever say
that he continually said it was an
African and I have spent five years
thinking why did you ever say it is an
African if you look at the organization
of a peasant society I think that
because of peasants are human beings who
depend on agriculture for a livelihood
agriculture depends on nature for its
survival in most cases especially in
African countries the vagaries of
weather have always first peasant
societies to adopt certain social norms
in the organization of peasant society
reciprocity work sharing extended the
family systems personal assistance in
terms of need our social arrangements at
peasant society is put in place in order
to ensure themselves against a risk of
crop failure leading determine and
salvation if you pick that value system
a peasant who has
no food will go to aware of neighbor and
asked for assistance the one will not
have medicine who is ill will go to a
world of labor and ask for assistance
within the value system the moral
universe of the peasant society the
peasant will expect that the the
neighbor or the friend or the in-law
will help that is the expectation the
neighbor who is well off will respond in
helping that peasant because to do
otherwise would attract gossip and
social sanctions in form of there will
be negative gossip and other social
sanctions like reduction in reputation
people look at you as a bad and hapless
man you do not help a neighbor this
moral universe has powerful implications
has powerful implications on how
politics gets organized for them when
you introduce it into politics where
politicians have access to state power
and have access to money then they can
use public resources to extend private
generosity to people whose loyalty and
support they need now in most African
countries in most African countries when
governments collect taxes and when
donors give aid through the state it
creates an opportunity for elites to use
this aid selectively to build a
political following rather than invest
in building function of public
institutions that can ensure an
impersonal application of public policy
you know if I am an American and I fall
ill and I'm totally poor you have
something here called Medicare or
Medicaid whatever it is called I sit on
TV but I would go to a hospital on the
best of my claim to citizenship I'll get
a service if I need a rod in my area L
got my you will participate in the local
consequence there and the rod will be
delivered in other words the benefits
that the state confers upon the citizen
are given through impassion through an
impersonal application of public policy
by institutions institutions that are
built on rules this
system and I think this is the biggest
challenge our continent is facing how
can we foster incentives for governments
develop a vested interest in building
functional public institutions that can
deliver public goods and public services
through public institutions or political
institutions in the passion alley to
anonymous citizens but let me come back
to the organization of these politics
now if a minister is in charge of the
healthcare system
he will still have the budget and his
other colleagues will steal another half
of that budget or the huge still a part
of the budget and others will still
another half finally only 25% of the
total health budget will go to the
health sector most of it will be
appropriated by individuals within the
state and don't make this mistake most
people say that the corrupt in Africa
steal this money and put it on their
Swiss bank accounts that is only one
part of the story the other part of the
story is that this money is used then to
extend private generosity to individuals
and groups whose support and loyalty the
politician is looking for so the
dysfunction the dysfunctions we see at
the level of his tissues because
institutions are staff and of rather the
fund sent to these institutions are
stolen by private individuals these
stations remain dysfunctional but if you
come to think of it this function is not
the way the system fails it's the way
the system works it provides
opportunities for those in power and
dollar and for those subject power to
use personal connections to benefit from
corruption how a politician who a
politician who needs support from a
given community will use the stolen
money to extend the private
kindness and generosity to the community
on the other hand elites who could
challenge this kind of practice realize
that it is it is much more profitable
and less costly to negotiate privately
with a powerful individual government
for resources rather than to organize
resistance against the state because
resisting the state is costly you can be
arrested and thrown in jail
your family members who have businesses
that can receive the tax auditors the
next day so it is much cheaper for me as
an individual elite in Africa to go to
the president and supplicate so that he
can have my mother put in the
presidential jet and evacuated to
Germany for treatment
rather than go and organize a newspaper
to be criticizing this kind of system
and it is through this kind of
relationship that the governments in
Africa are able to secure individual
compliance with the practices that are
collectively harmful but it is also the
strategy through which governments in
Africa are able to fragmented resistance
to the emission role now having given
that very brief organization of politics
how power is organized and exercised and
reproduced let us shock this model with
aid here comes the International Attell
of good intentions with a lot of money
from American taxpayers and says here
mister and remember the President of
Uganda you have won 1000 billion rather
1000 million dollars which is a billion
dollars you have a billion dollars you
are putting high a hyena in charge of
the meat market or we were putting
Dracula I don't know whether all of you
know you know but possibly not virtual
if you're putting Dracula in charge of
the blood bank
so here is the challenge with this kind
of organization of politics where this
function is the way the system works
rather than the way some failures how do
we how do we think about aid and how to
change this country's and this is moving
in with my conclusion I strongly believe
that the greatest catalyst to change our
threats when the governments are
threatened when elites are threatened
they are forced to change via bad ways
these practices we have talked about up
economical costly one they destroy Rada
so people cannot read they display they
destroy the health the education system
and therefore you cannot have an
enlightened
population a steel population that can
support economic growth they destroy
healthcare and when you have a disease
population they cannot work and produce
more
so the costs of these practices has been
to stifle economic growth in Africa when
economic growth begins declining
government's establish because remember
that the government's collect revenues
from taxation and tax if you will get
the high tax yield if you have a huge
output in the economy when the economy
shrinks you will have less tax revenues
governments elites in African
governments in Africa are insured
against the destruction of the domestic
economy by a huge influx of foreign aid
elites in Africa are protected from pain
the political price of the economic
stability by the subsidy called
international aid why is there a huge
political price for you can make the
claim government's everywhere in the
world need money to survive they need
money for us for the simple thing of
organizing law and order basic law and
order and our governments are quit
dictatorial in Africa they need money to
pay them and the police to clobber the
opposition they also need money to buy
off elites as they have told you to
bribe elites for their support but they
also need money for some bit of warfare
in order to win legitimacy and
acceptance in the eyes of the vast
majority of the citizens if the source
of this money for their own fiscal
survival is to be generated from the
domestic economy these government's
would be driven by self-interest to
govern in a more enlightened fashion to
listen to the citizens to have a vested
interest in the productivity of their
citizens and therefore sustain robust
institutions and productive economic
policies
the second thing first is eight tends to
reward those governments it perhaps
governments that have destroyed their
domestic economies by providing them an
international subsidy the second thing
because a this channeled through the
state it tends to increase the economic
attractiveness of politics and therefore
the profitability of controlling the
power when politics and power become the
most profitable economic activity in the
country especially our societies that
Nicolay heterogeneous then you will have
every ethnic group competing to have
access to the foreign aid pie and that
makes the struggle for entry into
politics or into power a matter of life
and death
finally aid tends to be such a to be
SATA to it from what have explained to
be saturated the relationship between
the state and the citizen how by making
the governments dependent on foreign
donors for money
they make these governments lose
interest in the productivity of their
own citizen
the result is governments stop looking
at their citizens as people to whom they
should be accountable but they look at
them as clients whose royal that they
should by using foreign aid dollars
equally the citizen stop looking at the
government as an institution or the
state that they should hold to account
through their own actions and they begin
looking at it as a patron on whose
generosity they depend for their
livelihood how do we change these
countries I just want to conclude by
coming to the role of threats the role
of threats in forcing to government's
change and I will tell a story about
these threats in 1999 December I went
back home to Uganda for Christmas I was
a student in England so I went you going
for Christmas and I decided to make a
telephone call to our president so that
I can one see him before the century
ends and he was generous to me and gave
me audience so we stopped that evening
the 31st of December 1999 and started
and then asked him but mr. president you
have one major problem since you came to
power the army has always remained
almost like a private institution to you
why don't you professionalize it and
make it a national institution and he
told me a story that has remained on my
mind for many years he said look when we
came here in 1986 that's when our
president came into government we
started he had come to power through a
guerilla war and therefore the army he
had was not really a national I am it
was a passionate guerilla army which he
needed to transform into a national
professional institution he
said we started sending a member of our
officers to two before training so that
they can come and build the office a
call of a national professional army the
problem is that everything we sent to
these offices forty to sixty percent
would be returned why would they be
returned because they had HIV and then
one day this is the time when HIV is
beginning to ravage Uganda I said one
day President Fidel Castro of Cuba
called me and said you're worried that's
the first name of our president you're
worried your ma is in serious danger it
is going to be wiped out not by the
bullets of the enemy our president was
facing a rebellion in the northern part
of the country not by the bullets of the
enemy but by the scourge of AIDS HIV
AIDS and the person told me when he had
that story he realized that really he
had danger he could easily be overrun
now at this time his political party
called the mrm had been very weak and
shaky a political base the instrument of
his rule was the army which had used
capture power so if this arm is ripped
out Marines would lose power the threat
of loss of power made him think I do not
know whether any one of you has read
about AIDS but Uganda is the one country
in the whole world that they designed
the most prevented the most effective
aids or HIV preventive measures I have
you have you can find anywhere we put in
place systems put in place policies that
because this is a disease that did not
have a cue at that time there were no
Arab is the most important thing was to
campaign for prevention condoms was
disputed through schools our parents
African cultures have the booze you can
talk about sex all of a sudden there
were there were national campaigns in
Uganda to encourage parents talk to us
about sex I was a young man of about 14
years then and my mother had convinced
me down and we had to discuss sex so
cultural taboos were broken institutions
were put in place policies and campaigns
were everywhere billboards and it was
aids and prevention of AIDS was a
like coca-cola on billboards on
television in newspapers if you go to
East Africa I think Uganda has the most
liberal newspapers we have a newspaper
called the red paper you should look at
Africa newspapers rather than they on
the internet so their role of threats
the second threat I could mention is
Rwanda in 1994 the little contrivances
suffered the genocide the people who
captured the power in Rwanda are the
ethnic group that were victims of this
genocide
these guys had stared mass extermination
in the eye and very few of them had
survived but part of the survivor was to
capture power and ratio it from definite
kutaro strength to kill them they
learned that the price of failure is
very high they cannot afford the lecture
of incompetence and corruption that you
find in most of Africa so if you go to
Africa today you'll find that that one
has one of the most effective Public
Administration systems anywhere in the
world its systems are as efficient as
you would find much more efficient than
the US as you'd find in Switzerland or
Sweden so we should appreciate the role
of threats that governments in Africa
have been protected from staring regime
collapse in the eyes through an influx
of foreign aid and as the consequence of
these things we have the following we
have the demonstration effect because
when one when Uganda started reforming
neighbor Saturday Singh
these guys are doing well what is that
they're getting right so once you have
one country threatened its 10 stitches
snipers right now all our neighbors have
adopted many of the policies even in
regard to edges of Uganda initiated in
the early 90s a reputation of capital
when if you can fu cluster of countries
begins growing rapidly international
investors begin saying in this country
is interesting we should be going there
so you gain reputation of capital and
finally the the final thing is the role
of individual and organizational agency
because whatever the threats Uganda
faced regarding AIDS or one in Spaziano
side context it was so important to have
an organization
a political party and an individual lead
in our case mr. m7 in Rwanda mr. Paul
Kagame an individual who can catalyze
the organization to promote the desire
to change I want to end my presentation
there and open it to questions queries
and questions thank you very much thank
you so much Andrew so there's an
opportunity for a few questions around
here thank you very much for this most
fascinating presentation i person have
learnt a lot I have a very brief
question regarding Wanda do you think
that part of the success story was and
please correct me if I'm wrong about the
facts part of the success of the
contemporary success story of Wanda has
to do with the fact that the Tutsi who
ultimately came to power are a minority
group in random policy so they have to
to make things work otherwise they will
always be resented because they are
minority so in other words if they were
a majority would the outcome be a
different one if they were an ethnic
majority after that's my point that's my
point
I agree with you I am suspicious I
cannot rule out that him who - one is
divided between Hutus and Tutsis the
majority Hutu who almost exterminated
the Tutsi I agree that the Wanda is
ruled by a tiny by a minority and ethnic
minority that stared extermination in
the eye so there is they face a strong
group threat that strong group threat
imposes on them a strong revenue
imperative they need money to build an
effective security system to defend
themselves against a violent power grab
so that ravine imperative
means that they have to build function
institutions have to have productive
policies that can ensure sustained
economic growth economic growth is vital
for one because generates the necessary
tax resources the government needs to
defend itself against a violent program
but violence rather coercion or the
military alone cannot be an effective
instrument of power they need the
software of rule and that is called a
JIT masseur how do you win legitimacy
when you are a discredit they
discredited minority they need to build
good roads have a functional health care
system or education system in order to
win the hearts and minds of the majority
who - and I think a combination of those
two things
explains why runner functions like that
but remember that also one has a history
700 years of a history of a strong under
for Italian state what has always had an
effective state and like many African
countries and Ronda was not created by
the colonial by colonial rule it
predated colonialism so I think that it
is possible even without these rates
that possibly a more productive Hutu
president can build on that rundas
pre-colonial traditions of an effective
state and the pursue a much more
productive approach but it would be very
unlikely for the Dutch it is very likely
for the Hutus it would be unlikely so
every with you on that
hi I have two questions the first
question is about the discovery of oil
in Uganda right now and how does that
change for example the the political
game especially for the case of you airy
and does this mean that I just read a
few articles days back in which people
are criticizing how the contracts for
oil were being handled and the
government has refused to what this big
open about them so how does this new
resource that has been discovered in the
country change things
and then another question is about oh
you just said about how liberal the the
newspapers in Uganda are but I've been
going through several newspapers and
this isn't concerned with the
anti-homosexuality bill which I'm not so
sure if it's passed or not but these
there is a strong as compared to Kenyan
newspapers which tend to be better
advocates of human rights the Ugandan
newspapers seem to be very much
conservative and how they say not making
enough efforts to really push for this
this one human rights for the LGBT
community in Uganda why why exactly I
mean do you think this will change in
the next you know will there ever be a
changed towards advocacy thank you very
much my friend from Tanzania I think one
regarding oil Uganda has been depending
on foreign aid for nearly 50 percent of
our budget and the foreign aid has been
responsible for the creation of the most
corrupt in your Petronio system I know
of in Africa since Moyes and Mobutu's
but this one is much even more elaborate
because mafias really smart guy thanks
be to the rest of university so oil is
likely to increase state patronage and
corruption in Uganda and even lead to
the institutionalization of very many
aspects of the Ugandan state regarding
the the Uganda is in Parliament they're
proposing a law to Hank everyone who is
a homosexual and to jail for life anyone
who touches another in a homosexual and
suggestive way you can incite is very
conservative by the way conservative to
the degree that if you call for a
genocide against homosexuals I am sure
95 percent of the electorate would vote
for that genocide
so it is in this context that you need
to understand the Ugandan press that the
journalists themselves would largely be
as prejudiced as the audience they are
writing for that is one and two as
ignorant about sexual diversity as the
audience narrating for but what has been
impressive for me is that actually if
you read the editorial pages of
newspapers in Uganda across the board
they have been defending or they are
opposed to this law so I am extremely
satisfied I'm actually surprised that
you're not satisfied with the position
you can read newspapers have taken you
may read at course opinions written by
the anti-homosexual coalition which is
very strong and I think they need to be
given a chance what is important for
uganda is that at least in a society
that is extremely conservative
especially on matters of sex with
exceptional aids that we have opened a
national debate on the rights of sexual
minorities and that debate it is through
fostering openness and open discussion
about sexuality that we can create
understanding and it is understanding
that can help you Gundams overcome
cultural by go 300 traditional
prejudices against homosexuals and the
newspapers in Uganda are doing an
excellent job I think have written about
three or four columns in my newspaper
you know criticizing the bill and the
wrong foundation philosophical and moral
foundations that underpin it
whether I speak very fast when use when
I speak 1,000 what is in one second
just do like this for me here so that I
speak in a foreign accent I think a bit
accent an American accent but still you
may not be able to globalisation seminar
which was a collaborative effort between
Yale University and the Tony Blair faith
foundation and Tony Blair was there
presiding over our session on faith and
aid and I took the opportunity to bring
up the thesis from Denby Samoas book
dead aid which is saying the same thing
that you are that perhaps foreign aid is
you know hurting more than its helping
and his response to my example was that
Africa's problem is not where they're
getting the resources and so which I was
disappointed in and I didn't get to
press the matter further so with your
experience I guess communicating with
these kinds of people in charge of
foreign aid and whatnot like what do you
think what steps may be taken to kind of
change this mindset and clarify what the
real effects are these good intentions
as we tell you that they have suffered a
similar fit like you when Tony Blair was
still prime minister he forms something
called evolution for Africa which was
supposed to design a new strategy for
delivering aid in Africa in a more
productive way and the part of the plan
I was one of those who was invited to go
and have a meeting with him to discuss
how how we can increase aid and use aid
as an instrument of economic development
and my discussions with mr. Tony Blair
convinced me that he was totally and
down-to-earth he is a kind man a nice
man who I had visit him by the trade
Hayek
that your good intentions in and of
themselves are not sufficient to deliver
what you want the Road to Serfdom you
see this presentation is some Hayek I
was saying that the road serfdom is
always preferred with good intentions
now you see I entered the
my presentation with the last word
covered with good intentions Africa and
the curse of foreign aid so I think that
Tony Blair among all the proponents of
eight is on extreme he's on the left of
should I cook say they left or the right
of Jeffrey Sachs he's even worse than
Jeffrey Sachs and this experience is
from my personal interaction with him
who had they were very kind of
discussion I would I found born or whom
I have had the discussion with including
yesterday along telephone conversation I
find the bond of much more willing to
listen and understand that good
intentions in and of themselves are not
sufficient good intentions can end up
propping a very corrupt system so I'm
very skeptic about Miss a Tony Blair but
I think that ap can work if the
conditions are to facilitate its ability
to work right if you do not have a new
much money organization of politics you
have an elites that have a vested
interest in sustaining growth like in
run as I have shown you with Uganda in
the case of AIDS and a laconic reform it
can be a powerful instrument of change
but in most cases Aid tends to reward
failure rather than to tense up stays
really irrelevant to reward
accomplishment or innovation this is
something I'm curious about you
described the sexual conservatism in
Uganda is that okay and you described as
traditional is it really traditional or
was it introduced by the Christian
missionaries a combination of the two it
is a combination of I think three things
one I think that there must there was
homosexual practice in the pre-colonial
African societies in some places it was
even condoned in certain parts of Uganda
and their research is to do that I have
always wondered why do mainstream
Ugandan remains from Uganda was actually
hostile from sexuality I personally
think that if a person who grew up in
Oregon or up and Ugandan never had a
form of sexuality that a man can get
sexual excitement from a fellow man or a
woman from a fellow man the first time
they hear it they think it's a wrong
thing that is I think the first reaction
I tend to think that beyond Chris
Jannetty and tradition is just people I
don't know whether this is a very
arrogant thing for me to say I think
that most people really very simplistic
they don't seek to understand the
complexity of a problem they look at
simplicity because people say this is an
unnatural thing yes then what do you
mean by nature you see I think that it
is a combination of many things and
often Christianity is just used
instrumentally to service Christianity
and the and tradition are evoked service
deeply entrenched ignorance or prejudice
I don't know whether I'm clear you can
subtract to shunt out of your gun and
pull out tradition those two things and
you'll find that people are hosting
trauma sexuality because yoga nandroid
is not exceptional explicit for most
people the discussion that the man
should marry fellow men and women should
marry for women is alien to them it's
not something they have grown in a
culture that has talked about it and
said it's okay so they have they have to
find an excuse or an explanation how do
I explain this wrong thing they say oh
my question values tell me it's wrong or
the swing and say traditionally it is it
is an African what I ask them what do
you mean it's an African if it did not
exist in the colonial society oh if it
did not exist then it means African
societies do not have gained a position
on it I'm gonna interact with interrupt
with one question here you this is the
privilege of holding the mic you you
mentioned the importance of existential
threats and I wonder if you qualify that
at all because the life expectancy of
the average African president is not
terribly long indeed you know the life
expectancy of African president is
probably lower than any other president
on the planet and if that wasn't clear
in 1962 it was certainly clear by 1966
it's very clear by by now so this
certainly suggests that an existential
threat whether to coup or civil war is
not a sufficient condition it may not
even be in my mind a necessary condition
for the the most successful in the most
and most sustained growth in the history
of the human civilization is Botswana
and and I and I without in the perhaps
is my ignorance of Botswana but I don't
see the existential threat certainly not
today
so I well it perhaps to to hiv/aids but
but that's a different character so I
wonder fifteen into that but SWANA
you see biggest issue threats also
talked about the role of individual and
organizational agency I think that they
in countries that have low levels of
institutional development the role of
individuals in the destiny of those
lessons is extremely important because
individuals can make many things happen
and in the case of Botswana the group
that captured the power at Independence
was led by the king so he enjoyed
overwhelming legitimacy the king of the
to Ana hosted 84 percent of the
population in raid over her missus
saturates akarma enjoyed overwhelming
legitimacy so there was no threat to his
power really to the coalition he built
to govern Muslim Botswana was a
coalition of traditional ranchers these
were people who had property so they had
a vested interest in a polity that would
support increasing returns to the
investment and the combination of those
two his legitimacy is the individual
character and the kind of organization
and the pillars of that organization was
responsible for sustaining robust
political institutions and public
policies the same happened for Kenya in
the kata periodically who captured the
power independence were extremely
profited and they had a vested interest
in promoting the productivity of their
private investments but in many African
countries the illicit captured power of
the independence and after where came
from dispossessed and disgruntled groups
and they looked at they looked at the
state as an instrument of distributing
the world that appropriate expropriating
those who owned the wealth largely the
Lebanese in West Africa Asians in East
Africa and European multinational
capital so the social base of the regime
or the political base of the regime if
it's
the veranda boys that are supporting the
regime of course it will pursue wrong
policies and when the political social
base of a regime is a profit in the
class it will tend to be much more
productive you could also see but lean
over cost and sir Felix mr. Felix a fat
boy near the first president so that is
one so it's a gents a it's the social
base of elites who are ruling it is the
level of the mobilization of different
groups in most of these countries really
the business class so the productive
classes are not not very well mobilized
but you may find ethnic identities
better mobilized and they're demanding
distributive policies it's a combination
of so many things but overall is that
when aid comes into a system that has
already become dysfunctional where
politics is organized around a new patch
money of logic it tends to accentuate
rather than to ease the problems now
about the existential threat in 1990 the
Soviet Union collapsed and Western
countries started pulling out aid from
most of the nations of Africa the
consequence was that most regimes in the
fracture became vulnerable in Benin
Matthew Carrick was vulnerable in Zambia
Malawi Tanzania Kenya all these regimes
all of a sudden become extremely
vulnerable many of them are forced into
political reform others who could not
reform did not have money without
foreign aid to finance the emmys they
collapsed under the weight of civil war
in Ethiopia in Somalia in Liberia in
Sierra Leone
others the amis mutant and they suffered
military crews so we can clearly see
that in a regime in financial decay is
also a regime at political risk and the
most important thing we should never do
is to get such a regime that I in
financial decay and give them a subsidy
from abroad we should let them sink can
you suggest let's say three good foreign
aid projects that you would recommend if
you were asked well I should recommend
them in this context that if you find a
system that is functional if you go to
the one that they have a very function
of state so I would recommend that where
you find things that work
you can use foreign aid to cuddle to
promote that the achievement you see the
problem with aid aid is attracted to our
failures not to our achievements so it
comes to fix our weaknesses not to
leverage our strengths and if you try to
fix the weakness of anybody I can tell
you the changes you get will be
extremely minimal at best
but you will tend to accentuate that
dysfunction because whenever you find
dysfunctional institutions you know that
they are powerful individuals who are
benefiting out from this dysfunction and
putting more money into a dysfunctional
institution will be like putting pouring
water into a bottomless pit so that is
one the second the second thing is even
within nations that are characterized by
dysfunction because governments are not
homogeneous the heterogeneous you may
find small pockets of efficiency in a
notion of incompetence identify that
which is innovative that government a
department that is relative and support
that wherever you see failure run away
wherever you see success support I think
that ad should reward innovation
it should never subsidize failure
finally I think that you can use ADA's
venture comfortable I think that we
should do in most cases where you have
dysfunction of city institutions
eight should as far as possible seek
innovative private sector and civil
society actors and sidestep the stage
you have some specific examples yes sort
of work one of the oh well one of the
examples that have worked in terms of
eight quite a number there so many small
little aid projects may have delivered
the baton in one village food in another
or build a hospital clinic the borehole
aid so many projects have worked in many
places
my argument always is that the problem
of the aid industry is to look at one
eighty project that succeeded try to
transplant that experience or that
success across so many countries and
regions across so many cultures ignoring
the unique conditions habits
nomes values skills that were unique and
peculiar to that village
and try to spread them across the whole
third-world thinking that they are the
experience of ever about it you see it
will be extremely effective if it was
selective and particular aid would be
extremely effective it was if it was not
given because the country is poor but if
it was given because somebody is
innovating something somebody's doing
something right you see the
qualification for getting aid is that
you're poor I think that severe on
qualification the qualification should
be are you doing something right how can
we support it are you doing something
wrong or will not touch it because never
indulge yourself in dysfunction if you
find a young boy here gambling in the
casino spending he's a the man on the
credit card or no bars and the cocaine
and we give them more money for them to
buy better clothes when they are going
to transfer okay they gave and to gamble
in the casino
that will not to be a formula for
success but if you find an kid here you
know extremely innovative Frank set up a
business or do some you know interesting
innovative and creative things support
that one so I believe in rewarding
achievement and innovation and
penalizing failure and the incompetence
yes sir well my question was going to be
to ask about your your thoughts on on
the merits of a dove conditional aid
that is aid that's rewarded after the
fact conditional upon institutional
reforms I think you've sort of just
addressed that so I'll ask a related
question and is what do you see is the
potential of aid to be an inducement for
institutional reform so of all the the
factors that contribute towards
institutional reform will we be able to
point towards cases of conditional aid
that is a deliberate after the fact
conditional upon institutional reform as
a mechanism for for institutional reform
well actually a question I think I
should have said something they forgot
to say that aid works in extremely rare
and exceptional circumstances at a very
difficult point and difficult to create
rare find and difficult to create in
that case in an actual spa institutional
building but that requires a convergence
of different but at least compatible
interest between the a deliverer and aid
recipient I'll give you an example of
Uganda in 1997 when our current
government came into office the current
president inherited the collapsed state
and the collapsed economy he clearly
understood that his ability to
consolidate his position in power was
entirely dependent on accessing money
money to put basic goods and services in
shops sugar soap salt and water these
things you take for granted here where
the luxuries in Uganda because the kind
of secretary collapsed that is one to
some statisticians were totally
dysfunctional so for him to consolidate
his position he needed to deliver goods
and services in shops but this t column
had also collapsed he didn't have
foreign exchange to import soap and
sugar and salt and the ordinary things
really
Karason and he realized he went to get
money from the international aid
community they insisted that we can only
give you aid if you wish an agreement to
the IMF and the World Bank the IMF and
the World Bank said we can only give you
money if you accept libre from disband
state enterprises disband state
monopolies deregulate the economy
liberalized the foreign exchange market
you know things like that
initially he accepted these
conditionalities out of desperation
rather than out of out of conviction but
in accepting visit conditionalities he
got money but Uganda's you see this case
is extremely unique that in the sense
that in Uganda you had a bureaucracy of
the state that was actually in favor of
these reforms and building of this
functional institutions and we had a
protocol class that was hostile to it
but the moment this bureaucracy leverage
that power and used this reformed
generate economy growth it was very
quick for the political class to see
that it is better to hold a small slice
of a growing pile hole smalls
for the growing pie then hold a huge
slice of a shrinking one another control
and interested that is whose economy is
collapsing Oh collapsed it's a bit at
Hollis verse Moore's rates of a state
that is able to grow the economy so the
combination of a bureaucratic all that
favored these reforms an institution
building a very pragmatic president who
was willing to you know take a chance
was able to create a modicum that
allowed the ILA construction of East
issues in Uganda which right now
he's working very hard to destroy so but
that is you need a combination of many
different factors so you can see in that
case there was a convergence of
interests but they were different the
donors wanted these reforms they
government wanted money for something
else total it consulate is position in
power I think that aid works when a
government's desire to hold and retain
power requires it to do those things
that have the greatest benefit to its
citizens when that kind of convergence
of the interest of power align with
interest of the citizen then ADA can be
an extremely functional instrument of
development policy hi um so you just
mentioned that mr. Denis is potentially
destroying the institutions of Uganda
and I was curious if you thought that
he'll have any serious threats in the
upcoming 2000 election 2011 election to
his political yeah he has significant
threats 70% of the abandoned population
is angry with him so that's a very big
threat okay I know that this opposition
does not find organized the political
expression because he has both of all
elites so he has disconnected at the
head from the body the head meaning
elite leadership from the body which is
the ordinary people for worship in any
system you have fellowship and
leadership by creating the largest new
patrimonio order you can imagine on the
African continent he has 114
presidential advisors he has a cabinet
cabinet ministers 71 cabinet ministers
he has 189 commissions and
semi-autonomous government bodies and is
dividing the country into small units of
local government here you call
States in Uganda we call them districts
he has now created 104 districts three
years ago they're about 56 now they are
growing every day and the district has a
parliament it has an executive it has a
super service a bureaucracy so it
creates so many jobs for elites all
these elites I integrated into his
patronage system at his finest by 8:00
and soon will be financed by oil so the
thing is that in a country with fewer
educated people a outside of the state
and the market there are few elites with
skills and experience and a national
profile to build an effective opposition
movement he has I think that although
the masses 70 percent oppose him they do
not have an organized and organizations
through which this content can be
expressed so they remain fragmented in
rural areas and unable really to have a
say on the national political process
and when it comes to voting he steals
the votes but if the opposition find
momentum something huge they can rally I
can tell you they will give him a run
for his money how useful do you feel it
is for the very small individual aids
projects for example finca fi NCA that
makes very small business loans to
individuals particularly women or heifer
international that provides chickens or
a cow or whatever to again to
individuals how useful do you see that
as a way of giving aid down to people as
opposed to governments actually McGinest
able agility governments I think that
I'd like that is people-to-people aid I
think is always functional because first
of all it's more scale so people can
pull out if they think it's not working
it's very difficult when the governments
have been engaged to disengage so I
think that's a very good thing most of
these people people ate most of it not
all of it supporting of innovative
things
um thank you very much for your talk so
far um so I have a couple of questions
um what are your thoughts on the
involvement of China and Africa as far
as it goes
because I mean historically since its
most of it has been from the west so far
and my second question is in your ideal
world
um do you I mean is it that you envision
absolutely no aid to governments period
um irrespective of whether the
government is I'm dysfunctional or well
is it like absolutely no a to government
like what what's the way forward you
just recommend completely just stopping
things right now like what would what
would your ideal world be someone give
you an extremist answer I think that if
I was a donor I would say I'm going to
be scaling down a by 20% to most
governments enough most not all that is
the first thing because I think that
most of them are really dysfunctional I
would begin much less like cutting it
and in five years they will be facing a
serious crisis now as they have said in
the beginning there are always
exceptions to the rule I would identify
either entire governments I have given
you one example the government of wonder
which I think I who do not even get
involved in what I do I will give them
budget support decide what you do with
the money because they know how to use
it well anyway the incentive structure
is different to within dysfunctional
governments I wouldn't buy those pockets
that work if you come to Bandar the
central bank at the Revenue Authority
the mistral finest they are fairly
competent and autonomous institutions so
I would support those government
institutions in those countries where I
think they're functional if I want Kenya
and Uganda and Ghana and Nigeria in
terms of health care delivery they have
a function of public private sector
systems that can deliver actual
education and house I would do possible
create a voucher system through which
the government would with I would I
would try to deliver aid through private
sector initiatives rather than through
dysfunctional public institutions you
see my approach is that I need to be
particular to the experience
if you ask me how do we give a premiere
I want that Zambia's political economy
how does it suicide to work is it
corrupt is it efficient how does it sir
how is its private sector is it
competent if you ask me about Congo
Mobutu's Congo I don't even think that
is a private sector where you can use to
deliver health care first of all it is
there and they don't know but largely I
need to understand the internal
properties of a given country and we
used those internal properties or to put
it the other way it is important to
appreciate the social endowments of a
given nation before you design the aid
architecture for it the aid architecture
must be specific to that country's
social endowments some countries are
very good through private sector
initiatives follow the private sector
others have powerful civil society
groups use those ones others have strong
and effective states use those
statisticians others have dysfunction of
states but they are pockets of
efficiency in goes some of departments
at the functional use those that are
functional I think there is another part
of the question about China China
regarding China you see I don't think
that Africa solutions lie with China the
Europe or anywhere they lie within
Africa itself Africa is in a bill that
benefits from external interactions is a
product of its own internal incoherences
so for me really whether it is there's
nothing Jenner can do that can change
Africa and this is nothing that was can
do that can change Africa except to do
nothing if they did not think they would
promote progressive change but if the
internal conditions within Africa are
right then African leverage the
institutional or poor strength it has
mastered internally to leverage its
external relations and get something out
of it
so if governments remain as corrupt and
incompetent as they are it does not
matter how much money China puts in I
have a two-part question the first is
along with foreign aid comes you know
the push for foreign cultural and social
norms and particularly human rights and
I know Uganda has
Human Rights Commission I've worked with
them a couple times and I was just
wondering what do you think is the role
of the Uganda Human Rights Commission do
you think it's in a fact of tools
actually being a watchdog against the
government and second of all do you
think that there is a culture of rights
that exists in Uganda Uganda is a
country in transition so the culture of
Rights that exists is one that is
growing there is a grow in the culture
of remember that they never forget what
Karl Marx called the catalytic the
catalytic function of ideas ideas on the
human race have spread across the whole
world and the people have embraced them
as their own
so in Uganda people promote human rights
not because they will not argue that
they have been influenced by their were
solo but maybe the fact but they have
been breasts and and internalized these
human rights issues they regarding the
UN Human Rights Commission I think it is
partly independent and partly this is
the contradiction about Uganda you see
sometimes it tends to exhibit
independence and try to hold the state
to account to human rights but sometimes
it also acts as a a public relations arm
of the government when it wants to hide
its Public Relation rather it's a
fisherman rights violations so I cannot
really give an answer that it is this or
that it's situation is much more complex
depending on the moment and the
intensity of the issue T's dealing with
I had a quick question about I want to
say very familiar with the Global Fund
country coordinating mechanism method of
allocating aid from the Global Fund
within a country yes what are your
thoughts on that is composed compared to
bilateral donors you see the the globe
of fun I talk about the Global Fund for
typical osseous eggs and malaria if you
go to the one that you will be amazed at
how effective they have used Global Fund
80 in fact if you come to Uganda we
stole all of it I don't know whether you
know they they gave us 240 million the
bureaucrats suppose
vans and politicians they formed energy
euros collected that money they both
prime real estate in New York in
Johannesburg in London when people here
in LA in the new heaven can't afford to
buy the real estate yet and the all the
money was stolen and the the sick and
dying remained on the events so I don't
think there is any international
architecture you can design that is
blamed to these peculiarities in fact
they argued in Uganda that they will not
deliver global fund money through the
state they will use the states to give
it to private organizations who can do
the work but what happened is incumbents
within the state organized it registered
hurriedly private organizations who came
under collected this money so the
organization of the country sport is
very important the government of Uganda
has long lost an interest in fighting
AIDS and now was interested in me using
aid as an instrument of patronage and
that's what they did the supporters of
the regime and a few opponents were able
to go and you know form organizations
and pick the money did you happen you
had
that's it work I should tell you in
Uganda they suspended the funding you
know why because the Minister of Health
in Uganda refused the wave of the
director of the Global Fund in Geneva
represented the company that was selling
malaria drugs so they wanted to create
the contract that all malaria drugs
should be bought from hack the company
she represented you see the Minister of
Health in Uganda had been I think given
something big by whatever it was he
refused when he refused it Geneva
Centene are not it the audit found that
all this man had definitely been stolen
it is because remember by the way that
the international aid bureaucracy itself
wherever it is is corrupt so the wife of
the director with the Global Fund wanted
to get this deal when Uganda blocked say
doctor will also you have you know he
does this side will hit you the other
side so they sent in Price Waterhouse
Coopers which is an international audit
firm which came and audited and the
found that is all this money really was
going to politicians and civil servants
and regime clients so they immediately
suspended with eight but the Ugandan
trade also reveal he said but no you are
attacking us because we refused to allow
your company suppliers malaria drugs so
the guy they had to resign so in this
case the Global Fund was able to acting
for Ghana because the International and
the lock where and able to align their
interests how do they aligned to them I
can promise you they're never exposed
that I think we have time for one more
question
a broader question it almost a
historical one you talked about the
ethnic rivalries ethnic had
heterogeneity in Africa is it first of
all is it a problem that has been
overstated second of all is it a problem
going back to Western colonialism as we
learn here at in our schools drawing
arbitrarily the borders on on on the
maps the colonialist had and if the
borders would have been drawn
differently would it have been a totally
different Africa more with more
stability and for the first two
questions they are both right one that
they think the problem with history is
overstated to that the the colonial
administrative innovations had something
to do with it but what I think is most
important is that what your question at
least on tribalism today is as modern
and as current as what is happening on
that day because people have the
identities but if I want to get access
to power I need something that can help
me create an emotion following around me
I can see in America here you have
people who organized as Christian
conservatives or something like that
sometimes they can even vote against
their own economic interests in pursuit
of some emotive
ideological aim or religious objective
so I think that anyone who can easily
strategize and call themselves the the
lead in Christian in America can easily
win over that constituency you I have
seen politicians in this country pander
to the Christian Right you know that we
need support so even in Africa
politicians would want to invent even
non-existent ethnic tensions in order to
rally a given community to stand behind
them and its current right now in Uganda
because Uganda spends 44 percent of its
budget at the level of the local
government the state level what you call
stats here half the budget almost goes
to those districts so but how can in a
commune to justify having a district
they say ah for us our tribe is this
their trips that they live existed in
the pre-colonial and colonial Uganda
which have been invented in the last
five years just to get the district so
you can see what is an identity an event
is something I can pull out of the air
and say now we have an yalla we want our
own district now we have a rule II now
we are aliens tomorrow we have radians
so new groups are cropping up new at
least as ethnicities and clans are being
born in Uganda today in order to have an
own district so that they can access
you know the central government
resources so that is the thing the last
question was a bit for your borders I am
NOT I'm not particular attracted to it
for one reason if you were to create
nations in Africa around the tribe these
nations some of them there are tribes in
Africa which have 50,000 people so
Africa to become a continent of not less
than 9000 States so I to be honest with
you as an African I personally think
that colonial is made a significant
improvement on Africa out of a group of
not less than 6,000 groups it created at
least 53 missions and since that time we
have we have added more rather than
reduced them so we have not first added
more unit in fact we added on Eritrea
since colonialism left that is one the
second thing is that even historically
they are no borders that were ever
negotiated with people states are
created through conquest wherever
generals fought to the last fought and
won the war is where they press the
border so even the borders of France you
know that Napoleon was born in an island
of Corsica which France had captured
from Italy one of those Italian states
in the Venetian Lambada whatever it was
just a few years before Napoleon was
born you see in America here there was
the Missouri purchased by Thomas
Jefferson you know America Danforth
mixed quite a good Texas and Florida you
know things like that but as a post
voters are creations of conquest they
there is no meeting where they say ok
for me I will fall into this country and
you know will rule son tried it after
the first world war and you can see how
disastrous it was
as an experiment of what do they call it
self-determination so I think that that
argument is really not rooted in history
the history of all borders is a history
of conquest and Africa was created most
most of the states of Africa with the
exception of Ethiopia were created
through colonial conquest
now the subjective effects of the
colonial state in Africa we're
disastrous on those who lived under it
it was racist
it was the exploitative it was
oppressive it was all bad many bad
things but the objective outcome of the
colonial project was to integrate many
of those countries into the
international system and actually create
some modicum one of a modern state
what Africa should be discussing this is
not the use of colonialism but how to
leverage the the minimum advantages the
colonial state left behind much more
viable entities of politic
administration the colonial government
left us in many countries in Africa left
us important bureaucratic traditions
that if we build upon would foster
economic growth and the well-being of
African citizens Botswana is the prime
example it built a lot on the function
of bureaucratic traditions ethics and
rules that were left painted by the
bridge colonial government so yeah thank
you very much